welcome to this video playing of rest
westfalia okay from germany yet which is
not so surprising let's see that no name
okay so probably a king's indian i have
played him quite a bit five games with
plus to school so we get the king's
indian classical again exactly the same
exactly the same thing as before a ton
okay sometimes it's crazy i would
coincidences you have but he knows how
to do it Bishop ahead bishop f6 when I
what I analyzed a little bit i showed a
little bit the end of the game before
word he went for for this setup you
should evade it's the same thing it will
come to e7 okay what what if i quickly
go for before yeah
not sure I don't think white normally
does that in this slide but doesn't look
too bad
Knight f6 maybe 9 f6f 3 quite often
black is some provoking f3 then takes on
e4 and plays Bishop h3 using this
weakness that has been created by g3
yeah Beck about 2,400 that's good was a
long struggle
John Knight f6 looks quite normal yet on
first this
yeah true that's also very much possible
so yeah the naija is coming to deform
I currently I'm slamming discovered but
I don't want to recapture with the f
pawn definitely not hmm that's a bit
awkward
they don't like that very much I
probably should have played f3 in
comparison that looks better you for
playing f3 to recapture on e4 with the
porn so that this night f5 activation is
not possible I think night deform is
some is a good move now yep okay this
might be a good as well I was thinking
it'd just make quite a bit of sense to
UM to have the epod kept taking on the
form okay so here what am i doing f3
yeah maybe f3 49 f to Bishop d3 or
something like that also want AMG for
covered yeah he's okay yeah definitely
no problem for black it's a surprising
didn't expect that c5 wasn't really
possible anyway so it might not hurt in
any way
yeah my pieces relates to the e4 square
nicely so I have a decent control over
the position but I don't have a clear
way forward Bishop Jake's is a bit more
interesting maybe yeah maybe this is a
bit more interesting not trading of
everything ok I'm happy that he allows
that that I can get the F out Queen a8
was was an idea I had quinsy three
though okay maybe no serious idea but i
think it's it's it's it's a nice
additional idea for whites to have Luke
a7 queen a3 this kind of invasion he has
weakened the light squares quite a bit
so you know it's quite nice and ok seven
Queen a three Queenie for this kind of
thing will pose a problem maybe ok so
Bishop g5 this is idea try to enter
okay let's do that
yeah that's an interesting idea of
trying to activate the bishop them so I
wonder if c5 is actually an idea but
that could backfire easily
I wanted to play Queen a forward I can
do that sorry I was a chip stupid idea
and then yes T still has the special b3
move and I can go to c6 that's actually
quite strong ok Luke I have seven let's
look ahead that's not going to happen
maybe he can take before but I was
willing to allow this transposition or
this transformation transposition is
wrong and now look look I'm sorry Queen
Queen here I'm not threatening them
that's important
the strange night is covering those
squares quite the time warning that's
crazy
oh that's so that's it sets a really
pretty strange it seems that um that was
so great actually neither six is an
interesting move I thought Queen d7 here
would be it would be a draw at least and
I'm happy with the draw now have to be
check check I can go to h3 right okay so
check there
no time check check can i play for a win
from how i can check him check all right
he's still in this still check has those
checks them check draw our third game
drown Jerry it's it's just a perpetual I
guess huh so where did I spoil that I
think around here should be quite nice
maybe not like winning or so but it was
quite nice this position huh what was my
mistake yeah maybe I should prevent that
in the first place yeah like this this
is this him it's this kind of move that
just prevents this Bishop move their
kind of saying okay those are looking
strange but I have an idea rook a seven
and so on while like maybe doesn't have
something yeah maybe that was good this
was awkward
computer is on 000 the whole time except
here kingi to with an advantage Wow ok
let's no check-in let's see i see that
but if he hmm if you just did this dad
why the winds ok yeah maybe check check
here h four winds ok yeah h form then
h10 h3 is a safe square yeah i see this
is winning okay now okay here's one
check but then it's over here something
and now i'm picking up picking up things
but it wasn't even difficult shame shame
shame shame shame shame shame okay
thanks for watching